le québécois éric gauthier est une
véritable rock star de la danse en
allemagne ni bhl des zones de
prestigieuses compagnies se l'arrachent
la télévision allemande s'intéresse à
lui il a même rencontré angela merkel et
il est aussi ambassadeur de la marque de
luxe mercedes ou cd chanteur connu puis
l'ont ils ont passé un artiste marque
c'est la danse de la danse en plus c'est
invraisemblable à sa sortie du ballet
national de toronto c'est sa
personnalité et son charisme qui ont
séduit l'une des plus prestigieuses
compagnies de danse au monde
le ballet de stuttgart moi je tape plus
dans le ballet c'est plus qu'un match à
lecce en plaine ont un peu jeté un
danseur qui pouvait faire vite pirouette
mais j'étais pas la presse selon éric
gauthier l'intérêt pour les arts est
beaucoup plus marquée en allemagne qu'au
québec
dans chaque ville en allemagne un petit
et rentrent ils ont leur compagnie
d'opéra de danse chaque petite ville on
parle d'une centaine de villes qui ont
un petit air qui est payé par
l'allemagne
le chorégraphe dave st pierre est du
même avis lui aussi a connu le succès à
l'étranger d'abord pense que l'histoire
l'art en général est beaucoup plus
importante en europe même peine pour la
danse en général autant du côté du
gouvernement que des producteurs il
interprète aussi des chorégraphes ne pas
avoir peur de se lever puis de parler de
ces problèmes là en fait 6 pi 2 de le
dire y a pas d'argent lorsque autant
pauriol
éric gauthier est décidé à rester en
allemagne
il abat sa femme ses trois enfants et sa
compagnie gotti danse j'ai toujours
l'espoir que quelqu'un regarde la danse
pour la première fois puis après le show
il bondit c'est sûr c'est la danse
aujourd'hui c'est la danse moderne ça
c'est la danse moderne jouets en bois en
plus éric gauthier à 41 ans et ils
dansent encore occasionnellement mais
son avenir pense-t-il passe par la
chorégraphie ici julie jasmin boudreau
radio canada montréal
[Musique]